30 seconds
shot
good afternoon everyone
i'm here to give you
an update on the illegal block cades can
i tell you about our
efforts to support ukraine
facing potential russian invasion but
let's begin with the situation here in
canada of course illegal blockades that
have been disrupting the lives of too
many canadians
here in our capital city
families small businesses have been
enduring illegal obstruction of their
neighborhoods
occupying streets
harassing people breaking the law
this is not
a peaceful protest
at the borders in different parts of the
country the blockades are harming our
economy and endangering public safety
critical supply chains have been
disrupted
this is hurting workers who rely on
these jobs to feed their families
yesterday the ambassador bridge was
reopened between windsor and detroit
our team and i have been working with
ontario and the city of windsor around
the clock i want to thank the officers
on the ground including the rcmp who
played an active role
we now have a responsibility to make
sure that the bridge stays open
with each illegal blockade
local law enforcement agencies have been
acting to keep the peace
within their jurisdiction
despite their best efforts
it is now clear that there are serious
challenges to law enforcement's ability
to effectively enforce the law
on friday ontario invoked a state of
emergency to respond to the blockades
this was the responsible
and necessary
thing to do
today
to continue building on these efforts
the federal government is ready to use
more tools at its disposal to get the
situation fully under control
after discussing
with cabinet and caucus
after consultation with premiers from
all provinces and territories
after speaking with opposition leaders
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades
and occupations
i want to be very clear
the scope of these measures
will be
time limited
geographically targeted
as well as reasonable
and proportionate
to the threats they are meant to address
the emergencies act will be used to
strengthen and support law enforcement
agencies
at all levels across the country
this is about keeping canadians safe
protecting people's jobs
and restoring confidence in our
institutions
here's how the measures we're taking
today
will help get the situation under
control
the police will be given more tools to
restore order in places where public
assemblies can constitute illegal and
dangerous activities such as blockades
and occupations as seen in ottawa the
ambassador bridge and elsewhere
these tools include strengthening their
ability to impose fines
or imprisonment
the government will designate secure and
protect places and infrastructure that
are critical to our economy and people's
jobs including border crossings and
airports
we cannot and will not
allow illegal
and dangerous activities to continue
the emergencies act will also allow the
government to make sure essential
services are rendered for example in
order to tow vehicles blocking roads
in addition financial institutions will
be authorized or directed to render
essential services to help address the
situation including by regulating and
prohibiting the use of property to fund
or support illegal blockades
finally will enable the rcmp to enforce
municipal bylaws
and provincial offenses
where required
this is what the emergencies act
does
that may be equally clear
about what it does not do
we're not using the emergencies act to
call in the military
we're not suspending fundamental rights
or overriding the charter of rights and
freedoms
we are not limiting people's freedom of
speech we are not limiting freedom of
peaceful assembly we are not preventing
people from exercising their right to
protest legally
we are reinforcing
the principles values and institutions
that keep all canadians
free
and after speaking with the leaders of
the opposition parties
the federal government has invoked
the emergency measures
to complete
provincial and territorial powers
in order to manage the illegal blockades
and occupations exactly i want to be
very clear
these measures will be
limited in time and geographically
targeted
they will be reasonable
they will and they will be proportional
to the threats to canada's security
the emergency measures act will
strengthen
and support
the work by the police
we are not using the emergency measures
act in order to deploy the military
we will not be suspending
fundamental rights
articulated in the charter of rights and
freedom we are not limiting the right to
peacefully protest
or assemble
is protecting canadians
protecting their jobs
and
reinstating confidence in our
institutions is not something that's
been used
ever
but it exists for a reason
invoking the emergencies act
is never the first thing a government
should do nor even the second
the act is to be used sparingly
and as a last resort
right now
the situation requires additional tools
not held by any other federal provincial
or territorial law
today
in these circumstances it is now clear
that responsible leadership
requires us to do this
these measures must be and will be
compliant with our charter of rights and
freedoms indeed the emergencies act was
created in the late 80s to flow from
and uphold the charter we'll always
defend the rights of canadians to
peaceful assembly and to freedom of
expression
but these blockades
are illegal
and if you're still participating
the time to go home
is now
on a separate track from the emergencies
act i want to reassure people that the
canadian border services agency is
already turning back non-canadians
trying to enter canada to participate in
blockades
and of course while we get the situation
under control
we'll continue to have canadians backs i
want to remind affected businesses that
if you're facing revenue losses
support is available through our wage
and rent subsidy programs we know that
downtown ottawa businesses in particular
have been hard hit by these illegal
activities
in the coming days
we'll be launching specific support for
those businesses
i know that everyone
is tired of this pandemic
we're hearing your frustration with
covet
and even with the temporary measures we
had to put forward to keep people safe
i know people are frustrated i hear it
you have a right to express that
frustration
and even your anger
with the government or government
policies
it's something we'll always defend in
this free and democratic country
but
blockading streets and critical
infrastructure and depriving your
neighbors of their freedoms
is a totally different thing
it has to stop
turmoil
everyone
is tired of the pandemic
there are other ways to express
yourselves rather than participating in
illegal activities and dangerous
activities
said last week
public health measures
are constantly being reassessed
and we will continue to
modify them according to science in fact
we will be making some announcements on
that subject in the coming days
today i also want to speak briefly about
our support for ukraine
on saturday
i spoke with president zielinski to
reaffirm canada's steadfast support
and to continue to do whatever we can to
support ukraine
during the weekend
i also spoke to
the
michelle
as well as chancellor schultz of germany
and president of poland as part of the
collective g7 response to support
ukraine's economic resilience today
we're announcing that canada will offer
a loan of up to 500 million dollars to
the government of ukraine i want to
thank deputy prime minister freeland for
her leadership on this file
and underlying that this is in addition
to the 120 million dollar loan offered
earlier in january
on top of financial support
canada has already taken steps to help
ukraine defend itself including with the
extension of the training mission
operation unifier
in light of the seriousness of the
situation and following conversations
with our ukrainian partners i've
approved the provision of 7.8 million
dollars worth of lethal equipment
and ammunition
this responds to ukraine's specific
request and is in addition to the
non-lethal equipment we've already
provided
the intent of this support from canada
and other partners
is to deter further russian aggression
so canada is joining
the united states
the uk
bulgaria czech republic
lithuania
the netherlands and poland in sending
arms
the goal
russia from pursuing its aggression
towards ukraine
confrontation with russia
but the situation is intensifying
rapidly
and we are showing our resolve
it's important for canadians and the
world to know that canada will continue
supporting ukraine and its independence
integrity
sovereignty
including its right to defend itself
thank you everyone
i will now give the floor to the to
deputy prime minister freeland
[Music]
[Music]
across the world liberal democracies are
being confronted with serious
and repeated threats
this siege and these blockades are
causing major damage to our economy
democratic and are harming our
democratic institutions as well as
canada's reputation in the world
international confidence towards canada
as a good place to invest
and
these illegal barricades are doing great
damage to canada's economy
and to our reputation as a reliable
trading partner
the blockade of the ambassador bridge
has affected about
390 million dollars in trade
each day
this bridge supports 30 percent of all
trade
by road between canada and the united
states our most important trading
partner
in kutz alberta about 48 million dollars
in daily trade has been affected by the
blockades
in emerson manitoba
about 73 million dollars in daily trade
has been affected by the blockades
these costs are real
they threaten businesses big and small
and they threaten the livelihoods of
canadian workers
just as we are all working so hard
to recover from the economic damage
caused by covid
during when we were negotiating
we will never
let those hard-won victories
be tarnished
the world is watching us
our jobs
our prosperity
must be
and they will be
as part of invoking the emergencies act
we are announcing the following
immediate actions
first we are broadening the scope of
canada's anti-money
laundering and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd-funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies
the illegal blockades have highlighted
the fact that crowdfunding platforms
and some of the payment service
providers they use
are not fully captured under the
proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing act
our banks and financial institutions are
already obligated to report to the
financial transactions and reports
analysis center of canada
or fintrac
as of today
all crowd funding platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
must register with fintrac
and they must report large and
suspicious transactions
to fintrac
this will help mitigate the risk that
these platforms receive illicit funds
increase the quality and quantity of
intelligence received by fintrac
and make more information available to
support investigations by law
enforcement into these illegal blockades
we are making these changes because we
know that these platforms are being used
to support illegal blockades and illegal
activity which is damaging the canadian
economy
the government will also bring forward
legislation to provide these authorities
to fintrac on a permanent basis
second the government is issuing an
order with immediate effect
under the emergencies act
authorizing canadian financial
institutions to temporarily cease
providing financial services
where the institution suspects that an
account is being used to further the
illegal blockades and occupations
this order covers both personal
and corporate accounts
third we are directing canadian
financial institutions to review their
relationships with anyone involved in
the illegal blockades
and report to the rcmp or csis
as of today
a bank or other financial service
provider
will be able to immediately freeze
or suspend an account
without a court order
in doing so
they will be protected against civil
liability
for actions taken in good faith
federal government institutions will
have a new broad authority to share
relevant information with banks and
other financial service providers
to ensure that we can all work together
to put a stop to the funding of these
illegal blockades
this is about
following the money
this is about stopping the financing of
these illegal blockades
we are today serving notice
if your truck is being used in these
illegal blockades your corporate
accounts will be frozen
the insurance on your vehicle will be
suspended
send your semi-trailers home
the canadian economy needs them to be
doing legitimate work
not to be illegally
making us all poorer
il
it's all about following the money
is used in these blockades don't replace
your corporate accounts will be frozen
the insurance on your vehicle
will be suspended
send your rigs home
can again add this one the canadian
economy
needs them to do legitimate work
to illegal and not
make us all poorer
illegally
to ensure laws are being complied
and
canadian democracy is being protected as
well as our economy over the past two
years
we have trusted one another
we've leaned on one another
what we are facing today is a threat to
our democratic institutions
to our economy
and to peace order and good government
in canada
this is unacceptable
it cannot stand
and it will not stand
thank you and i'll now turn over the
floor to my colleague or attorney
general minister of justice david
lemetti
so
thank you deputy prime minister
thank you prime minister colleagues
canadians
good afternoon
canada is a rule of law country
by declaring a public order emergency
under the emergencies act
we are following the law
and we are acting within it
there are clear conditions set out in
the emergencies act in order for a
public
order emergency to be declared
our government believes that those
conditions have been met
and that requires the government of
canada to actually
ways first of all
the emergency service
has several ways of safeguarding uh
measures including parliamentary review
secondly measures taken under this act
circumstances that amount to a national
emergency
for a situation to be qualified as a
national emergency three conditions must
be met
first
we must be in a situation that either
seriously endangers lives health or
safety of canadians and exceeds the
capacity or authority of a province to
deal with it
or seriously threatens the ability of
the government of canada to preserve the
sovereignty security and territorial
integrity of canada
second
the provinces and territories capacity
to handle the situation must be
considered insufficient or must show
gaps
and third we must conclude that the
situation cannot be handled adequately
under any other canadian law including
provincial laws and territorial laws
declaring
once the emergency has been declared
the emergencies act allows the federal
government to let
necessary rules or decrees in order to
in order to resolve this crisis quickly
and safely
the emergencies act also contains a
number of significant limits checks and
safeguards
as required by the act earlier today and
on occasion over the past week the prime
minister and members of cabinet have
consulted with premiers and members of
their respective governments
having now declared a public order
emergency we will table the declaration
in parliament as required within seven
days
in the coming days a parliamentary
committee will be struck to provide
oversight while the emergency is in
effect
the declaration
only lasts for 30 days unless renewed
however we can and sincerely hope to
revoke the emergency much sooner
parliament also has the ability to
revoke the declaration of the emergency
as set out clearly in the act
once an emergency is declared the
emergencies act permits the federal
government to make necessary orders or
regulations to deal with the emergency
the prime minister gave the broad
outline of these in his remarks
there are six specific measures we feel
are needed to bring this situation under
control
first the regulation and prohibition of
public assemblies that lead to a breach
of peace and go beyond lawful protest
what we are seeing in ottawa
and what we saw what we are seeing at
the ambassador bridge are not lawful
protests
second designating and securing places
where blockades are to be prohibited
this could include borders approaches to
borders and other critical
infrastructures or
ottawa
directing persons to render essential
services to relieve impacts of blockades
on canada's economy and this could
include tow trucks and their drivers for
compensation of course
authorizing or directing financial
institutions to render essential
services to relieve the impact of
blockades including as we have heard
from the deputy prime minister
regulating and prohibiting the use of
property to fund or support the
blockades
measures enabling the rcmp to enforce
municipal bylaws and provincial
offenses where required and finally the
imposition of fines or imprisonment for
a contravention of any more order
or regulation made under section 19 of
the emergencies act
they declared
as required by law parliament has the
power to revoke
response the emergency which means that
all measures
taken will be reasonable enclosed and
appropriate i want to emphasize one
point clearly
these measures are
temporary
we intend to impose them for only as
long as needed to restore order across
the country thank you merci
thank you minister alamedy the prime
minister and ministers will be taking 30
minutes of questions starting in the
foyer
starting with david turton from cbc
hi prime minister
a number of premiers today have come out
and said that they don't want or need
the federal government to exercise its
emergency powers
in their provinces so i'm just wondering
how do you respond to the premiers
who've come out today and said that
i thank the premiers for having had the
conversation with me this morning it was
extremely important to talk about what
was happening right across the country
we have seen
challenges
across the country that are
linked to
what we are seeing
here in ottawa what we're seeing at
border crossings
but allow me to repeat what i said
before
the measures brought in today
are geographically specific and targeted
only to where they are needed
these are not blanket powers across the
country these will be tools that can be
used
where and when necessary
so that the police of jurisdiction
dealing with
blockades or occupations
have the tools necessary and can draw on
rcmp resources as necessary
to keep canadians safe
to restore confidence
in the rule of law and in our
institutions and to make sure
that our economy continues to recover
from the impacts of covet 19 over the
past two years
at least one other premier said that
invoking this act is like putting oil on
a raging fire
words along those lines
do you think you're inflaming the
situation even more by invoking this
my focus is on canadians
who've had a long two years
who've been through a pandemic who've
lost loved ones
who've seen businesses struggle
lost jobs
and just want this to be over
they're exhausted we're all exhausted
we're all frustrated by the pandemic
but those people who disagree
with the measures that governments put
in place
to keep canadians safe to ensure that we
would make it through this pandemic
better than many of our peer countries
those people have gone from
protesting
and disagreeing with those measures
to limiting
and blocking
the freedoms of their fellow citizens
hurting jobs
hurting lives and livelihoods
endangering public safety
and weakening our country not just right
now
but
for times to come in the eyes of our
most important trading partners
these illegal blockades
are hurting
canadians and they need to stop
every step of the way
we have been there to support the police
of jurisdiction
we've been there with tools and
resources to help end these blockades
but it is clear that there are more
tools necessary
and that is why we are moving forward
with time limited geographically
specific
extremely bounded
measures and additional powers
that will allow us to get through
these blockades and occupations and get
back to the business of rebuilding our
lives
and our country
after this pandemic next question
is hello
[Music]
would you be prepared to go forward and
er
to move forward in provinces who do not
agree with the application of this act
answer in conversations
that we're having across the country as
well as with uh with premiers and as
well as with police services we are
working on managing various situations
across the country
and those conversations will continue
the emergencies act
is there to provide us with additional
tools
and provide additional tools to the
police services that are on site
in order to
automatically manage situations as they
emerge it's not automatically an
intervention by the federal by the
federal police
or a direct intervention by the federal
government
we're here to provide more tools
including
additional authorities
whichever police it has jurisdiction and
it's there
it's quite possible and we even hope
that the tools
we have provided to police services
across the country
will not
have to be resorted to
certainly not for very long
ideally
these premieres who say that they have
the situation in hand will continue to
be able to do so but
on a national level
we have reached
criteria
forcing us to act
to provide more tools to
those who maintain order in our country
to protect
canadian all canadians
across the country
you're saying that it's unnecessary it's
been through we're in the third week of
the
these protests in ottawa now why did you
not do this two weeks ago don't you
think that you failed in your leadership
responsibilities and
moving forward on this earlier
some people will say that we move too
quickly other people will say no we
should have acted weeks ago
the reality is this
the emergencies act is not something to
take lightly
it's not the first
thing you turn to or nor the second nor
the third one
we were there to provide additional
resources from the very beginning to
ottawa's local police service and
elsewhere
we were there to
support them in the work that they were
doing
and in the last few days
during meetings i had with ministers
with our partners
with
officials
are what we will be using through the
emergencies
next question that the rcmp now have the
ability to enforce provincial and
municipal laws does that mean that
they'll be the lead police force agency
here in ottawa and when can we expect
more police officers from the rcmp to
work with the city of ottawa because
they've been asking for that for a
substantial period of time
as i said the invocation of the
emergencies act
gives more power to the police of
jurisdiction it does not
make the rcmp automatically police of
jurisdiction anywhere across the country
as we have been
we will
ensure that the rcmp continues to work
to support
local police of jurisdiction
and that's what we have been doing in
ottawa but i think on this question i'm
happy to turn to minister mendocino who
can give uh further uh further
information on uh on the situation in
ottawa marco
yeah
thanks very much uh prime minister
from the very beginning of the
illegal blockades the federal government
has been working closely with
local law enforcement where they are the
police of jurisdiction including here in
ottawa i would point out that we've sent
three
install installments of reinforcements
to ensure that that ottawa police
service has
the support they need
but i think as we've seen without
question there have been many many
challenges
on the ground to restoring public order
on the streets and one only has to look
at the situation on wellington street
over the past number of weekends
i think it's difficult to overstate
the impact of those scenes the conduct
that has uh that has unfolded by those
who are participating in illegal
blockades
um it is not just an inconvenience
it is not simply a matter of
um
a trivial interruption we've seen
intimidation harassment
and expressions of hate
and at times
the scenes on the streets of wellington
have seemed
completely lawless
and that is one of the reasons why
we've had to take the very careful and
deliberate step
of introducing the emergency
emergencies act today and the
declaration and the specific
powers which again
are very targeted they're very
proportionate and they're time limited
so that there can be greater agility
between the rcmp who will work
seamlessly with
local law enforcement including in in
ottawa uh to to restore order
i would also say that while we have seen
progress for example in windsor
that we should not assume that that
progress is linear
and that is one of the reasons why these
measures through the declaration are
also necessary
we want to be certain that
local law enforcement has
the the concrete tools that they need
for example tow trucks which have been
very hard to come by
in addition to that the kind of jersey
barriers which will assist
with with crowd control that will ensure
that trade and traffic
can move very efficiently
and in addition to that when it comes to
the the relationship between the rcmp
and local law enforcement and provincial
enforcement
the provision that is within the
declaration will allow the rcmp to be
more efficiently
assigned to those areas to uphold the
law be they municipal laws provincial
laws
or indeed
the the designated zones which will be
prohibited from assembly because they
may cause a breach of peace
or may interrupt our critical
infrastructure through trade so when you
look at the suite of the measures that
we put into place today and we've
certainly put a lot of thought into that
our view is that they are necessary and
they will assist us in dealing with the
illegal blockades and bringing them to a
peaceful and expeditious resolution
as my follow-up mr trudeau mr mendocino
just mentioned that when you look out on
wellington street here you see lawless
scenes
why do you have any faith that the
ottawa police after three weeks now is
going to be able to turn things around
and restore law and order in this area
in regards to the ottawa police we have
been working closely
not just the rcmp but
the opp
to ensure that there is a coordinated
approach on that but
in terms of confidence in the police i
think we could do worse than turn to
our minister of emergency preparedness
bill blair
to respond to that bill
thank you very much prime minister and
good afternoon everyone
um the the rcm excuse me the ontario
ottawa police service remains the police
of jurisdiction in the city of ottawa
but the the police services right across
canada and certainly in ontario have
been coming together and they recently
announced on friday the the formation of
an integrated um command structure for
the for managing this event and then
that really brings the resources and the
capacities of the opp and the rcmp to
the assistance of the ottawa police uh
we've also had conversations with other
police agencies across ontario and and
they recognize the situation here and
the importance of of ensuring that there
are adequate resources but it's it's not
simply an issue of resources but also of
authorities and we have been working
from the very outset with with the
municipality and with the province in
order to ensure that our police services
here in ottawa and right across canada
have the authorities they need and and
the resources they need to do the
important job now as i said yesterday
policing is a very important institution
in our society we need the police to do
their job of upholding our laws to
maintain the rule of law and to maintain
public order and safety in our
communities and we have a responsibility
to make sure that they have the
resources and the tools that they need
to do that job they have our support and
and and as as that support
grows in in the city of ottawa i have
confidence that they'll be able to
restore order with the support that
we're providing
next question
hi prime minister stephanie taylor with
the canadian press you emphasized we're
not calling in the military to deal with
the situation but all options as you
said last week are on the table so what
would it take for you to bring the
military into this situation what would
the criteria be and what would it take
for you to make that decision
um
i'm not going to engage in hypotheticals
right now i think what is most important
is that canadians get their lives back
their communities back their
neighborhoods back
and can once again rely on their jobs
and the trade and the supply chains that
are supporting them and putting food on
their tables
the reality is the measures that we put
forward today
which have been carefully thought
through
will give the tools to law enforcement
to be able to move
in
even
stronger and clearer ways
against these
illegal protests these illegal
occupations
and blockades
that are hurting canadians
we will continue
to monitor and we will continue to do
the things necessary to keep canadians
safe but like i said
this emergencies act in no way
brings in the military as a solution
against canadians we are empowering law
enforcement i think that's what
canadians want to see
over the weekend minister blair
expressed uh that he was a little
baffled by the lack of law enforcement
he saw i want to know what you think do
you agree with him that it is a little
baffling the ottawa police are not
enforcing more of the laws what do you
make of the police scene you have seen
to date on wellington street and
elsewhere in ottawa
i think there are
there is a high level of frustration
amongst uh residents of ottawa uh that
this situation has gone on as long as it
has
certainly the frustration people feel in
ottawa has been echoed across the
country
and indeed around the world
and it is important that
the police of jurisdiction working with
the opp and the rcmp
are able to put an end to these illegal
protests the
specific and limited measures that we
are putting forward today as part of the
emergencies act will give them further
tools that in their
coordinated response between the ottawa
police services the opp and the rcmp
working together
should be able to
respond to these concerns by the
citizens of ottawa who want their cities
back
we'll take one last question into foyer
before turning to the phone yeah uh
prime minister ryan templeton national
post uh over the weekend mayor jim
watson here in ottawa made a deal with
protest organizers to move more trucks
onto wellington street and out of
residential areas i'm wondering if you
can give me any reaction to that
deal i know that the city of ottawa its
police services and its uh elected
officials have been pursuing an end to
these blockades
this has gone on far too long it is no
longer a lawful protest
at a disagreement over government policy
it is now
an illegal occupation it is time for
people to go home the measures that
we've put forward today
will be additional tools for law
enforcement at all levels
to be able to
secure an end to these blockades
you're announcing today rules around
preventing banks from dealing with these
illegal blockades the city of ottawa has
dealt with these legal blockades don't
you find that problematic that they have
cut a deal to put more trucks directly
in front of parliament hill
we are working
in a concerted way
on measures that will hopefully
restore order to the city of ottawa and
allow residents to get back to their
lives the measures that we put forward
today around
empowering banks
to follow up
and to
ensure that funds are not used for
illegal activities such as blockades
will be significantly helpful
in
in reducing the size and impact of these
blockades
thank you we will now move to the
telephone operator go ahead please press
star one at this time if you have a
question
silver play attributes of it
the first question will be from
come into effect for police officers did
you announce
[Music]
in the coming hours the coming days that
will have specific impacts
i will ask the medical minister of
justice to tell you more
messi um
thank you prime minister thank you mr
fidelio
the orders and decrees come into effect
immediately
thank you
mr trudeau several people reproached you
for your tone towards the protesters
over the last couple of weeks they said
you threw oil on the
flames
do you feel any responsibility for the
scope that these protests have reached
and what we are now seeing across canada
is that of course
people are tired frustrated sick of the
pandemic
tired of public health measures
they want it to be over
get vaccinated at a higher rate than
most in in most of our peer countries
across the world
demoted
lives disrupted by these blockades here
in ottawa
uh
seeing people suffering
because
borders are being blockaded that are
providing people that are preventing
people from doing their jobs
and are curtailing our supply chain
those people
are angry
and even
they want us to act
to restore order in our country to show
that we are a country
rule of law
or yes we do in this country encourage
peaceful
protests
we encourage people to openly and loudly
express their opinions but we do not
accept
economy
people who live
come and
curtail other people's
freedoms their fellow citizens freedoms
and break the laws and have illegal use
illegal means to protest thank you
murphy
the next question is from la prochaine
question eddie thunder mccharles toronto
star please go ahead avola parallel
thank you um prime minister i didn't
hear um an answer about the to the
question mack asked about reinforcements
from the rcmp to the city of ottawa and
if you can answer that great but
how specifically do you justify giving
even more powers to police in ottawa
when many residents and policing experts
say the law enforcement here has not
used the power they already have under
existing laws that this is a failure of
policing leadership not
the need for more power
there will be time
later to reflect on
all the lessons that can be learned from
this situation
right now we are ensuring
that local police of jurisdiction have
both the legal authorities that they
need
to
do their jobs but also the extra
resources we have
delivered
not just
rcmp officers as the opp has delivered
opp officers to support the city of
ottawa
but we've also provided integrated
planning and coordination task force to
ensure that we are able to actually see
an end to this occupation of ottawa
following up
um
yes i'd like you to speak if you could
you mentioned as did minister freeland
um the reputational damage to the
country that you feel the border
protests have had and the um
impact on canada's
i guess reputation as a reliable trading
partner but can you speak a little bit
more about just what was the tipping
point for you in all of this was it
really the fact that the white house has
been weighing in and burning up the
phone lines all weekend to all your
ministers really why have you moved to
do this
uh
for me
the conversations i had with our windsor
mp eric kasmercek who was talking about
the impact of the disruption of the
ambassador bridge
almost as soon as it started happening
the impact on
workers in the auto sector in the
windsor area and up the supply chain
through southern ontario
the direct impact hurting
exactly the people that
these
convoy protesters are purporting
to represent
regular canadians
are hurting in their jobs
in our economic recovery
in their freedoms to travel to see
friends and loved ones on the other side
of the border
because of illegal protests and
barricades
we have been there to support
local polices of jurisdiction
and we are now putting forward fresh
tools to do that
in terms of the reputational damage in
my conversations with fellow leaders
around the world on the situation in
ukraine and others um
it has been clear that this is something
that democracies around the world are
concerned with
countries that did well
during the pandemic with high
vaccination rates and strong public
health measures
are still seeing
backlashes against those measures
and
frustration by people who are tired of
this pandemic
and the
impact of
social media and
illicit funding
of
concerted activities designed to
destabilize a country that has the
highest vaccination rate of many of our
peer countries canada
around an issue that is not dividing
canadians canadians are united in having
been there for each other through this
pandemic and they're even united in
being sick and tired of this pandemic
but the way to get through it
is not to shut down our economy and hurt
our neighbors and that's something that
people understand around the world
and with this measure here today showing
that canada remains
a country of the rule of law
that will protect its critical
infrastructure that will support
good jobs
that deliver
deliver goods and services not just to
canadians but people around the world
are going to be protected
operator next question please merci
the next question is from la princian
question
boris
the next question is
capacities are not
sufficient to deal with the situation
i'm very pleased to hand the floor to mr
lamity to answer that
the answer can be found
and provide them resources that they
need
i would direct your attention i would
direct your attention to uh measures
announced by the deputy prime deputy
prime minister and minister of finance
today
uh the uh it's the uh
abilities
several different flags with canadian
albertan quebec flags these trucks are
registered across canada
and i thank mr ford
for having taken measures in ontario but
what we've done today
to do something here in ottawa or at the
borders or elsewhere
or through our financial services in
canada a
fair
affair
a
and under such
measures under such an act we can do so
we cannot do so through provincial
legislation
follow-up question yes
minister
what if the province does not want you
to
apply these measures in their province
can they ask to be excluded
of course we will continue to
collaborate with provinces
which we have done and we will continue
to do that
a national emergency has been declared
canada these
measures apply across the whole country
one last question on the telephone
thank you
just for a quick follow up
[Music]
obviously
these rules apply across canada
but the tools that we are offering
measures we will use will not be applied
across the entire country they will only
be applied
where they are truly necessary
it will only have a concrete impact
where it is truly needed
and that is not everywhere in canada of
course
operator merci
the last question is from
walsh the globe and male please go ahead
avola parol
good afternoon prime minister
minister lamedi if i understood him said
that this will apply across canada and
that provinces will not be able to opt
out your opening statement said that
this would be geographically targeted so
can you please explain where
specifically in canada this will apply
i i actually just answered that in
french and i'm happy to repeat it
because it is an important point that
people need to understand
the emergency measures act as it is
applied when it is a national emergency
that touches more than one province as
this one is
necessarily
covers the entire country because it is
a federal national emergencies act
however
the specific provisions that we have
laid out in the act
the measures necessary
we'll only apply
where they are needed
we talked about geographically limited
obviously
to can continue to ensure
that the ambassador bridge remains free
and clear for traffic
that is a place where the measures
brought in by this emergencies act
will matter
a
small community elsewhere in the country
a long way from borders or critical
infrastructure that is not experiencing
any
significant illegal protests
are unlikely to see any impact from
these
emergency the emergency act
this this is the element that is limited
to where it is needed and indeed in
places where there is a significant
border crossing where the local police
of jurisdiction
have no need of additional
rcmp support or even the additional
tools that we have made available to
them
they will not have to use
those additional tools
so even though the emergencies act
applies to the entire country
it is targeted time limited and
geographically specific based on
need
as to where it will actually be felt and
have an impact on the ground
following up
thank you so can you please clarify then
will it apply in emerson manitoba coupe
alberta and surrey bc and how will you
measure the success of this that this is
not just your government appearing to do
something but that actual results happen
well i think canadians know well that
the measure of success will be can we
get our supply chains back can we
get uh end the disruption to livelihoods
of people who rely on trade to the
united states from these border
crossings can the citizens of ottawa get
back to their daily lives
including as we saw just a few weeks ago
when a perfectly peaceful protest
involving tractors and trucks of
potatoes from pei were on parliament
hill highlighting their concerns that is
how this country needs to work and how
protests can and should unfold
but this
illegal occupation needs to end and that
is where
we have now given the specific tools
necessary for that
in regards to
emerson and kutz
one of the issues that we have seen is a
challenge in
getting tow trucks to actually show up
to
bring out to to move
these large rigs
in
in windsor
we relied on
generous partnership with the americans
to be able to get tow trucks to move the
big trucks
now with these
measures that we've put in place there
will be an ability to compel
for just compensation
tow truck owners and operators to
actually do the jobs for which they have
contracts with various orders of
government to keep highways and roads
clear
this is an example of a specific tool
that is now available
to
local police of jurisdiction in places
all across the country if needed it
would be to them to determine whether or
not that is needed
thank you this brings today's press
conference to an end thank you everyone